a Georgia couple who say that they gave
their son marijuana to treat his
seizures is now fighting to regain
custody of him Matthew and Suzanna brill
are charged with reckless conduct and
they could face jail time the state took
custody of their fifteen-year-old son
David in April when he tested positive
for marijuana
Omar Villafranca spoke with the Brill's
who say pot is the only thing that
helped their son for our son it was a
miracle for him Matthew and Suzanna
Brill say their 15 year old son David
went from having up to 10 seizures a day
to being seizure free for 71 days after
he began smoking marijuana have you ever
had 71 days where he didn't have a
seizure
never currently medical marijuana is
legal in 29 states and Washington DC
nine states and DC allow for legal
recreational marijuana but Georgia has
some of the strictest marijuana laws in
the country physicians are not allowed
to prescribe marijuana for medical use
and it is illegal to sell or possess it
but the law does allow those with the
state issued medical card to possess low
THC oil the only way he get a medical
card would be a 6 year waiting list so
the Brill say frustrated with
traditional prescription medication they
took matters into their own hands you're
having to buy it illegally yes Matthew
brill says he smoked the marijuana first
to make sure it was ok before giving it
to his stepson you guys got arrested yes
you both go to jail for six days the
brillz
were charged with reckless conduct after
someone alerted to Georgia Division of
Family and Children Services on April
20th David was removed from the Brill's
custody
that date he had a seizure and had to be
rushed to a hospital how is David doing
when I talk to him tonight 10-minute
phone call I was allowed to have with
him he's on the vertical wing and a
seizure
David is currently living in a group
home about 60 miles from his parents the
Georgia Division of Family and
Children's Services said in a statement
case managers continued to work with the
parents so the family can be restored as
quickly as possible their fee
real criminal charges Rachel kugel is a
criminal defense attorney I think even
if they beat the the criminal case they
still are definitely in hot water with
regard to Child Protective Services in a
statement the Twiggs County Sheriff
defended the charges against the Brill's
saying it is my duty to enforce state
law the Brill say they understand that
but they were just trying to help their
son do you consider yourselves criminals
no I'm a father did whatever it took to
make sure my son was okay Omar
Villafranca for CBS this morning Twiggs
County Georgia it's a complicated story
really bad for the young boy which there
was another way they could work that out
like what the father said I'm a father
who is just trying to do right by my son
and that's what the loss was to do to
protect the kids when their parents
aren't doing the right thing by them
they clearly love their son and they're
trying to do the best they can we can
help maybe that doctor can provide
something else that's having the benefit
of stopping seizures 71 days that's
that's Homer thank you for bringing us
that story